the reason that the left wants all these
open borders is because say what you
want all these people are coming in are
votes and I'm not saying the illegals
can vote but their children their
grandchildren they're trying to destroy
us and tradition I don't care what
anybody says bro well you think that
these people are so pro-immigration and
legals because they love these people
really think about that but I know a
bunch of liberal Cycles in California
I'm like you you're so open up come on
every everybody come in what are you
doing to help them you're not letting
them come into your freaking house what
oh remember Adam you always say follow
the money okay follow why not one dollar
for securing the Border why are they so
open why do they love open borders those
people's kids grandkids all becomes
votes and that trust me when they come
in and say hey remember who let you in
here the the right the Republicans were
like the hell with you they're racist
you're rapist but now remember Democrat
always vote Democrat and that's how
these cats keep